tina und damit das missverständnis
heute beginnt mein b2 kurs an der halo
deutsch schule
das wird sicher schwierig aber ich bin
gespannt darauf neue dinge zu lernen
hallo lisa schön dich zu sehen
tina du musst mir unbedingt erzählen wie
es gestern auf deiner arbeit noch lief
mir hat es gefallen weil das team net
und der chef sympathisch ist
es kamen noch einige gäste
ich habe viele drinks gemixt und das
trinkgeld durfte ich behalten
das freut mich für dich komm wir gehen
rein weil unser kurs bald beginnt
[Musik]
es nimmt nicht wunder ob wir hier im
kurs neue freunde finden
stimmt es wäre spannend neue leute
kennenzulernen
schau da kommt noch ein schüler
hallo zusammen
das glaub ich jetzt nicht lisa das ist
der gast von gestern abend
wirklich was für ein zufall mach schon
sag ihm hallo
hallo ich heiße tina was du gestern
abend nicht im café
ja stimmt ich heiße daniel hallo tina
ich komme aus polen woher kommst du
ich komme aus den usa
und neben mir sitzt lisa sie kommt aus
japan
hallo daniel ist das dann erst der kurs
an der halo deutsch schule
ja aber ich habe schon viele videos der
schule gesehen
die lehrerin ist da ich glaube dass der
kurs jetzt beginnt und welche eindruck
habt ihr vom unterricht ich finde die
lehrerin kompetent und sympathisch
ja das stimmt und der unterricht macht
spaß weil wir viel sprechen und die
übungen sehr abwechslungsreich sind als
die lehrerin dem witz erzählte musste
ich lachen
dir wird die schule sicher auch gut
gefallen daniel dann bin ich doch mal
gespannt was in zukunft so alles
passieren wird
ich habe eine ganz andere frage
weiß jemand von euch wo ich hier in
zürich basketball spielen kann
ehrlich gesagt habe ich gerade keine
idee ich bin nicht so sportlich weißt du
da etwas lisa ich weiß dass es einige
öffentliche plätze hier in der stadt
gibt zum beispiel im seefeld das ist ein
guter tipp da würd ich mal vorbei
schauen
ich gehe jetzt nach hause ich muss heute
abend noch arbeiten
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag
[Musik]
hey leute darf ich mit spielen kannst du
den spielen wir sind die besten spiele
der stadt soll ich als es beweisen dass
ich mit dem ball umgehen kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und was sagt ihr zu meinem new yorker
stil
unsere karriere ist zu ende du bist viel
zu gut für uns
ach was kommt schon wir spielen ein zwei
gegen zwei
ich will mit dir im team sein nein ich
[Musik]
hier sind eure getränke ich hoffe dass
ihr euch schmecken
[Musik]
danke
so sieht es aus wenn viele gäste hier
sind schön
so leute meine schicht ist eigentlich
seit 30 minuten zu ende
farhan übernimmst du jetzt bitte
entschuldigen meine verspätung li na du
weißt ja dass der bus nicht pünktlich
ist
ich finde es nicht so nett dass du zu
spät bist und ich heiße tina und nicht
die ina oder lina es tut mir wirklich
leid dass ich gesperrt bin shao bitte
dass das nicht wieder vorkommt
ich habe ab gemacht deshalb muss sich
wirklich gehen
tschüss zusammen endlich feierabend
jetzt gehe ich zur lisa weil wir
zusammen einen film schauen wollen
hallo daniel und schönen abend euch 2
halo tina ich sehe dass du müde bist ich
wünsche dir auch einen schönen abend
schauen wir mal ob unsere
arbeitskollegen schon da sind
[Musik]
was machst du denn für ein gesicht tina
du hast doch heute daniel kennengelernt
deswegen solltest du doch glücklich sein
ich habe daniel sogar zweimal gesehen
aber heute war er mit einer frau im café
lu
ich denke dass das seine freundin war
weißt du denn dass es seine freundin war
sicher bin ich mir nicht weil ich ihn
nicht danach gefragt habe ich wollte nur
noch weg
weißt du was ich werde ihn morgen in der
schule ganz beiläufig fragen damit du es
in zukunft weist
das finde ich gut
lasst uns jetzt den film schauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]